The joe rogan experience.
It looks like you'd just have a huge marble.
I've never understood the pipe white market I've probably had in my life,
maybe 10 paperweights.
I don't think of that dead.
I've never had a bit where I'm like,
my paper has been so out of control.
I just,
I just shut.
We knows.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm a window shutter.
I see that as an easier fix than just paper blowing everywhere or,
and plus there's so many outside,
like in your yard,
if you really needed something to weight it down.
A book is one.
Anything's one.
Like these people who,
who've made us think that it's an actual invention that we're like,
we'll build an actual glass object with a spindly thing in the middle.
Yeah,
and then everybody else was like,
Oh shit,
we got to get involved with that market.
Right.
God Damn,
we've got to jump on that globe.
Wonder,
I wonder if it's patented or patent.
It could be patented,
painted.
Is that how you would say thing?
That's how I would say it,
but I still think that's the wrong way to say it.
In my accent.
But you just take it with me speaking like a Todd.
I don't think it was,
I don't think it was anything to do with being Australian.
It's so bizarre how similar Australians are two Americans,
even though like,
you know,
you guys have a different accent,
the accents a little,
a little odd for us,
you know,
I think we're seeing more similar to the British person you are as well.
But I mean it's,
it's amazing how you go there.
What I'm going to,
by the way,
uh,
the way,
I mean,
and it's like you just could fit right in.
The accent melts after a day,
and that's just what people sound like.
And it seems like you're in America.
Well,
I don't notice the American accent now on anybody at all.
It's only when I have to do an audition and they make me do the American accent
that I get a bit shitty with the whole thing.
Oh,
do they do that?
They would make you change your voice.
Yeah.
And like I fucked that one audition.
I got a couple of callbacks and then I said the word,
uh,
I said,
I went to the zoo and I saw a zebra.
I still said Zebra in,
and he just said that I still set it in an American accent,
but with British phrasing and they freak the fuck out.
I need to hear more of this American voice.
That was a creepy voice,
dude.
Why?
Why is that so creepy?
What else?
What are we going to do,
dude,
that is creepy as fuck you talking with an American voice.
That is crazy.
Like I said,
it w I'm sort of,
I wouldn't say synonymous with Vice.
I can't a lot on stage and people always want me to say,
can't like when they have photos and it talking about in my accent,
if I say can't,
it's,
it sounds great,
but even when I state can't,
as an American,
I've go,
Ooh,
well that's a bit harsh dude.
You sound like a totally different human when you look at that fucking cut over
there.
Come on.
What was,
you never think that's Jim Jefferies?
There's no way.
I would think that's,
yeah,
I know,
but that's the thing is called me up.
That would freak me the fuck out.
I'm tell you right now,
don't do that just because of the sound guy.
Is that the no,
it doesn't sound,
it sounds,
just want to speak to you very quickly.
We have a few problems here right now.
It sounds vaguely fucked up.
Like [inaudible] it doesn't sound right.
It sounds really good though.
It's so close to like a real person.
Not like there's something affected about doing an accent.
Joe,
I want to hear you in and,
and do it.
He kind of make a deal like a fighter.
I'm still actually,
it wasn't bad but I like putting on a second.
I would say we don't say shit.
We don't,
we don't.
I do more English like,
well mine's 50 50 cause I lived in England for 10 years,
but we don't say the word.
We don't say the word shrimp.
No,
this is like Americans go prawns,
shrimp.
We call them prawns.
Right.
Paul Hogan does that fucking commercial where he goes,
all right,
we'll throw another shrimp on the Barbie for you like that.
Right.
And now that's like synonymous with Australians strains when that's not even a
word.
We say I appeal,
yell that out at American gigs,
but when I'm on stage,
go do the shrimp thing.
I'm like,
what the fuck off?
Isn't it weird how many like crazy personalities have come out of Australia?
Like the crocodile hunter?
All Hogan Crocodile Dundee?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He was out.
Diana.
Yeah,
crocodile and I go to l.
Dot.
He was here.
He lives around here somewhere.
Does it kangaroo Jack.
They only did a couple of those crocodile dundees though and then there were
done.
I would have thought that could have been like some Indiana Jones type shit.
I know they do.
The third,
the third ones are Pauling.
The third one's always strive to Davey Day.
Yeah.
And it's,
and it's like case was,
the whole idea was a crocodile.
Dundee went from Australia in the outback of Australia to New York and it's
like,
what the fuck's he going to do?
This is such a different place so you can survive out there,
but he can't survive here.
So that happened for the first two films.
Then for the third film,
you think let's send him to another country like Britain or somewhere else.
That's different.
It's Crocodile Dundee.
Nla.
Now the thing is,
he's been living since the last crocodile benefit Dundee film.
He's been living in New York for over a decade.
And then he gets to La and he doesn't know what's going on.
Why it gets too alarming for him.
Like what are all these people wearing sunglasses for?
This is weird,
cheesy.
These women's breasts are too big.
Like it's,
it's not a great film.
And in the end he becomes an animal trainer,
uh,
for the movies.
Any foils,
a robbery.
An animal.
Actually now I look back at it.
It's a great film.
I,
you ready to record recording?
Oh,
it is already.
What the fuck's on?